bill cosby has essentially been set free
on a legal technicality
but within hours of the decision he was
back at his home
appearing before the cameras with some
of his lawyers
we always believed full fully that he
never should have been prosecuted
because there was an agreement made he
relied on that agreement
and you can't have a system where
prosecutors don't hold up to their words
essentially what the supreme court is
saying is that bill cosby
should never have been arrested because
there was a
non-prosecutorial agreement in place
that prohibited our office from
prosecuting him
in 2015. cosby himself tweeted
i have never changed my stance nor my
story
i have always maintained my innocence
andrea constant one of the women who
brought the assault charges against
cosby
released a statement saying in part
today's majority decision regarding bill
cosby is not only disappointing
but of concern in that it may discourage
those who seek reporting or
participating in the prosecution
an opinion shared by this former city
prosecutor
there's no other way to spin it it's
definitely going to have a chilling
effect on other women
coming forward and particularly when
they're coming forward
against powerful men in positions like
bill cosby
so it's a sad day there's no other way
to say it is this a blow to the me
too movement i i
it's not a win but uh
it's certainly uh
a moment in which we all understand
that it's a long road to justice
and you know there are many roadblocks
on the way
while the pennsylvania supreme court did
not exonerate crosby
it made clear in its opinion he cannot
stand trial
on the same charge again
mike hannah al jazeera washington